hi there hi there steve here you know in
a few hours
i'm getting on a plane and i'm flying to
london where my son lives with his wife
and two children
and we're gonna spend a few days there
and then we're flying on to
israel uh i should point out that i'm
going to be participating in an online
uh seminar on language learning which is
going to take place over three days
i'm leaving a link in the description
box on the 20th of october
hopefully i have and i'm sure i do have
proper wi-fi in my room there i'm going
to be delivering my presentation on
language learning which is only one of
many by
a number of the leading
polyglots
on the internet sharing their
perspectives their experience on
language learning so
if you are available at that time slot
and i'm sure it's available at other
times as well check out the link in the
description box
all right today uh you know what i think
i can get myself a little closer
today
i want to talk
about what i think our two
absolutely essential ingredients for
success in language learning i always
come up with something along these lines
but it usually it usually reflects
something that i've been thinking about
the two are your curiosity
and link
l-i-n-g-q
the website that i'm a co-founder of and
which i'm on all the time and where i
have learned
nine languages in 10 years and i'm
learning greek right now
and i was thinking about this as i'm
saying you know
i'm about to get on the plane so i'm i'm
you know fully loaded with
uh agreed lessons on link with all kinds
of stuff that i can do i've even i
bought myself another greek grammar uh
online an ebook which i found
and which is now loaded into my uh and i
went by the way i went to uh you know
chat or at least amazon is one big
bookstore but chapters indigo in canada
is our biggest bookstore and they have
an online
uh you know sales thing where you can
also buy ebooks and they had a really
good selection
of uh books on a variety of languages
including some collins grammar collins
grammar for french which i bought which
looks really good really you know just
the essence of what you need
so anyway i'm fully loaded and i'm
saying myself you know i have everything
i need like
more than was available in uh the old
days in a in a language lab at school i
mean i have it on my ipad which i'm
using right now to film this i have the
same stuff on my little
ipod nano here
i can subscribe to audiobook services
with this
uh i can download texts uh ebooks and
and
import them into here which is what i'm
doing for greek for example where i'm
listening to this fabulous
uh podcast about the acropolis
which i'm having transcribed and which
i'm learning on using for my greek
learning on link and i'm on you know
episode six now and i'm reading it so
much more easily than i did before
so
link but it starts with curiosity
so as another example i i was planning
to go to israel and then to crete
and i've been spending all this time
listening and reading about the
acropolis and how it was built and how
they worshipped and and and you know
the design and things of that nature and
i'm saying to myself i'm doing all of
this and i'm not going to athens so i
changed my plans and we're going gonna
you know leave crete a day early arrive
in israel a day late
and we're gonna have three days in
athens so i can look at the acropolis
but it's just this you know it's
curiosity i'm curious about greek i
start learning greek then i be
discovered that there's all this useful
and interesting information about the
acropolis so now i want to go there so
curiosity is the great driver
and and so as i said the other day what
you start with whether you start with
and i'll show you i have it right here
here if you start with benny's book
that's great if you start with a more
conventional
uh starter book that's great
uh
you know many different ways to to get
sucked into learning a language but for
the long haul for the long haul towards
fluency i think i have to say it i think
link is just amazing because
for example i just had a brief workout i
was listening to my many stories in
ukrainian so i have all the languages
romanian whatever russian that i studied
before
and they're all on my
ipod nano and in my ipad and my iphone
and plus the the greek that i'm i'm
working at right now
so you know curiosity is so important if
you have the position that i know
everything i know everything better than
anybody else i'm not curious you know
it's like uh i think it was aristotle
who said i wasn't socrates i don't know
i know that i know nothing you know if
you feel that there's still so much to
learn
then you're curious and then you want to
learn you want to learn the language you
want to learn about the country and all
of this
generates this tremendous motivation
and i think if you're genuinely curious
then you start to really enjoy this
process of discovery
one thing by the way on the process of
discovery i was having a chat with um a
greek tutor
and so she starts explaining to me the
you know the relationships between
different words in greek or how some of
them are
you know we can understand them from
words that we're familiar with in in
english and so forth so having her point
that out to me
is a little bit
takes away the pleasure of discovery i
have discovered some of those things
i'll discover some more it's a bit like
if i'm playing golf and i'm trying to
line up my putt and the person i'm
playing with tells me yeah i would uh i
would aim you know
three uh
club length to the left or something
that takes the fun out of it in a way so
i think you know if you ask for this
kind of help that's fine but otherwise i
think it's that pleasure of discovering
things on your own
you know discovering connections between
words discovering aspects of the culture
and all of this of course it's it's it's
driven by your uh
curiosity still a little wet from my
workout my shower here
so so curiosity drives you and then you
need the tools and the tools can be
anything it can be to get you started
duolingo it can be
you know teach yourself books
a number of people commented
after i did my review of benny's book
which i gave a very positive review of
and people thanked me and they've
enjoyed benny's book and but some people
say they enjoy duolingo as a way of
getting into the language so whatever
you do whether you go to school you use
duolingo use
benny's starter books which i think are
available for five languages
nevertheless i think as a companion to
that
link is i i don't want people criticize
me for tooting my own horn if you want
but i think it's just such a tremendous
way of staying the course as you proceed
on your road to discovery
of the language and the culture which
eventually takes you to fluency so
that's what i wanted to get off my chest
today curiosity and link all right and
check the description box for the
information about this uh online seminar
about language learning
and
so i'll stand i'll close off with saying
you know
again on the same subject so i'm gonna
get on the plane in another four or five
hours
uh it's always difficult to move to to
get to break your routine and i'm i'm
going with my wife so it was less of a
in a way a disruption than if i were
just going off on my own for two weeks
and yet so it is a disruption but i'm
driven by my curiosity i want to see
these countries and once you get going
it's so stimulating to travel to see new
countries and different people and the
way different people live and language
learning is the same sometimes you got
to kick yourself
get going
[Music]
hopefully driven by some curiosity and
then the more you get engaged with it
the more stimulating it is the more
opens up
new vistas and that's what's going to
happen to me in another few hours as i
go off to see
offers for london but then israel and
crete and athens so thank you for
listening and
see you next time
[Music]
you